[Musique]
et on commence Gabriel avec un incendie
survenu hier dans les Yvelines oui la
célèbre école de commerce HEC a pris feu
ce mardi soir peu après 20h au même
moment le chef d'entreprise est haut
fonctionnaires Jacques Attali était en
conférence devant des étudiants 150
personnes ont été évacuées mais aucune
victime n'est pas déplorer les 60
pompiers Yves Linois sont parvenus à
arrêter l'incendie aux alentours de 23h
le toit de l'amphithéâtre Blondo s'est
effondré les autres bâtiments étaient
épargnés pour l'instant aucune décision
Grégory n'a été prise concernant une
suspension des activités de HEC selon un
communiqué de l'Université de fs2i c'est
un fond de solidarité entre les
départements franciliens
et il a pour vocation de porter une
soixantaine de dossiers à Visé sociétal
et départementale entre les sept
départements franciliens les présidents
des départements étaient réunis ce mardi
3 octobre au domaine de madame Elisabeth
à Versailles ils ont présenté les 158
millions d'euros qui seront alloués aux
différents projets dans les Yvelines il
y aura le financement pardon d'un
institut de recherche autour du sport et
du handicap au Mureaux je vous propose
qu'on écoute pierre bédy le président du
département des Yvelines c'est un fond
qui
porte des projets qui ne pourraient pas
porter qu'au seul échelon départemental
qui ne sont pas de la compétence
régionale et donc on ne peut pas
demander à la région de payer ce qu'elle
n'a pas à payer et donc ce sont les
départements qui s'associent et qui
mettent un peu d'argent pour justement
porter ses projets c'est c'est vraiment
la démonstration que la coopération
entre les collectivités produits des
résultats tout à fait remarquables
et on va parler à présent Gabriel d'une
plateforme créée par l'État oui
histologue vient de voir le jour pour
lutter contre le mal logement la
plateforme permet en une seule démarche
sur son site de signaler sa situation
une fois le signalement expliqué la
plateforme se charge de transmettre
votre dossier au service territorial le
mal logement c'est plus de 7 millions de
ménages qui vivent dans des conditions
très difficiles sans accès à l'eau au
chauffage au sanitaire avec ce logiciel
le gouvernement espère trouver des
solutions rapides sur 52 départements
déployés plus de 16000 personnes ont été
enregistrées et plus de 1700 foyers sont
sortis du mal logement on termine avec
un événement qui se déroulait cet
après-midi du côté du centre commercial
Westfield Vélizy 2 autour d'une célèbre
émission de télévision
Fort Boyard ont pu rencontrer les
célèbres passe partout et passe-muraille
ce mercredi 4 octobre à
Vélizy-Villacoublay le duo était
accompagné de l'animateur Olivier Minne
tous les trois ils ont présenté un
action game officiel de l'émission
au sein du centre commercial vous l'avez
dit on écoute les réactions au micro de
Michael el Mido le concept en fait c'est
comme dans Fort Boyard c'est de c'est
d'être en immersion dans dans l'esprit
en tout cas de ce que de ce qu'est le
programme et de ce qu'elle forme il y a
donc des cellules il y a des épreuves
qui ont été reconstituées et recrées
comme dans Fort Boyard il y a évidemment
la salle du trésor il y a le Conseil on
se les croirait et c'est une belle
aventure pour les gens qui vont venir
essayer tous ces jeux et les tester bien
sûr j'y participe depuis 34 ans ce jeu
est limites on a envie d'y jouer on a
envie de le découvrir pour bien s'amuser
en famille
sur TV 78
Fort Boyard vous êtes fun en plateau
forcément merci Gabriel pour toutes ces
informations alors contrairement à ce
qui est indiqué de temps en temps nous
sommes bien le mercredi 4 octobre et non
le mardi 3 octobre il y a eu les deux
dates qui sont affichées au cours de vos
informations mais nous sommes bien le
mercredi 4 octobre et si vous aussi vous
êtes témoin d'une actualité qui vous
fait réagir près de chez vous n'hésitez
pas à nous la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news